today's topic Chris D'Elia has come back
with some receipts proving a lot of
detractors to be liars oh yes you know
the girl who started all of this yeah
she's like he say groomed me when I was
16 so he ghosted her for like two three
years and then she emailed when she was
21 she's like hey I'm 21 now
DTF and you know what the thing is right
she admitted at that she that's the
problem she took - right and so a lot of
these people were throwing accusations
claiming that he was going after them
when they were underage had been proven
false one of the girls who went to his
stand-up show and I took a picture with
afterwards and then he said yo can I get
your number I want to see you sometime
here's the thing he assumed that she was
18 because she came to a stand-up show
because generally speaking when we do
stand-up they serve alcohol venues are
18 and over or 21 and over depending on
what the drinking age is at the place
where you at that's right so what ended
up happening afterwards soon as he found
out that she was young and she was
trying to hide it he ghosted her and in
another instance where a girl claimed
that you know he knew I was underage
this and that he hit her up and he's
like yo how old are you and she said
like 12 as a joke say no really how old
are you
and she's like 21 so she lied about her
age to him and so when you look at this
stuff and you see these people getting
so comfortable on Twitter to throw
accusations around and they want to
Klout chase a little bit but then once
new information comes out you realize
that they emitted a lot of the context
it makes a lot of them seem super
disingenuous however false accusations
only make up 3% of all accusations what
are we talking about this because all
those things that we just brought up are
not gonna be counted as false second or
not so the statistics are skewed so
everyone threw him under the bus his
agency dropped him all those people in
Hollywood who claim to be his friends
dropped him without any of the full
context and it was just so fascinating
to watch from afar and it goes to show
you how the court of public opinion is
so easily swayed by bad faith actors and
that's why I wasn't ready to condemn him
and I said I'm not gonna include any of
the under-18 because there's no evidence
that he knowingly pursued women who were
under 18
the only evidence I had at the time was
one girl who said his age her age and he
stopped talking her so when I look at
that information I'm like how am I gonna
condemn a man for some that may be
potentially illegal in some states when
there's no evidence of that being true
then everyone did that they condemned
him they called him a creep they said
he's the worst he did there's literally
no evidence of that because of a roll
it's so disappointing to see how people
are so easily swayed but just because a
lot of people come out and say something
doesn't make it true
this idea that strength in numbers
inherently means that there's validity
to these props isn't necessarily true
the absence of evidence is not evidence
this is why I'm very careful to call
anything up because so much of it is
fake so many facts important note
information is emitted and when we go
out of our way to cancel people based
off limited information what we're
essentially doing is that we're
subverting the law and we're saying we
don't need Jha we're gonna punish people
well guess what mob mentality often
targets the wrong people these are
exactly what witch hunts used to look
like the only difference that now it's
not people actually dying it's just
their careers that's what we just did we
watched a man be burned at the stake for
something he'd never did and what he
wants to see with women between 18 22
that's his prerogative that's common all
over the world it is what it is and also
your things like well he shouldn't be
getting involved with fans fans
shouldn't be trying to get involved with
him but it's a reality that exists on
our world who doesn't want to sleep with
someone they admire a lot no matter what
the age difference is yes top line
ladies yeah and man yeah people act like
famous importantly predator predatory
because they sleep with people who will
admire them news flash most of the women
I've ever slept with have admired me to
some degree or liked me and respected me
in a tremendous amount of way
and that was before I did you too how
I'm gonna say admire but fair oh yeah oh
yeah people watch me dance as I admire
you
ah yeah exactly i'ma give it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah brother
Abbas ooh brother King the third has
brought you the facts girl I didn't need
no
not on a computer I hacked down no no no
no we're going back in the video we're
not starting with it again all right
we're good
again damn damn damn you don't want to
hear the truth again again again testify
your name is preach preach a fie on this
might its Spotify create your account
[Applause]
boy you psycho celiac you the truth will
be heard
that's fire call it do do that higher
then the stratosphere above your head
we're going through a new elevation
let's elevate our canes is that what it
is every every video is gonna be like
you doing slam of course for the
brothers must be educated Jesus brother
Abba on the scene to review that
edumacation black power but ya know what
happened how do you know we were talking
it's very important in this day and age
there whatever things like that
happiness you don't scream wolf
screaming wolf like that messes up the
real problems and the real problems that
women in women face and real victims
when will real victims are gonna come up
and say stuff like that it's just gonna
make it harder for them because nobody
gonna is gonna believe them it's already
hard enough for a woman or man anybody
that is a victim of any kind of assaults
to come forward and to speak up
you're doing a huge disservice to the
actual victims
you should be charged as a predator in
my opinion if you fake someone's you
miss them on career up by some fake
allegations you should face the law just
like a predator tini Thank You Al
occations it should be the same which is
I I think I think misremembering
experience is one thing but when you
have written information where you can
omit things then to me it seems a little
bit more insidious and just to go back
to the other point about you know the
power dynamics guys do we talk about
women who take advantage of dudes in the
friendzone as somehow being criminal
because there's a lot of women who do
that mm-hmm
how's that any different they're using
her position of elevated power as a very
attractive woman to take advantage of
dudes hey which is very known for that a
lot of these platforms are known for
that is that wrong you know this idea
that you can't engage with your friends
are we saying that these people are not
mature enough to make decisions for
themselves that they need to be
protected what are we getting at we're
basically infantilizing our public in
our society and trying to say that
people have no agency and no ability to
make decisions for themselves I just I
don't like the ideas so we want to make
this video to kind of give you guys an
update since we made the first one
pretty much everything we said the first
one still stands you should still get
compassionately and all that stuff but
you know some people who were
grandstanding who were being super fake
now we know they're like he didn't groom
these people these were fans that he
approached once he realized what age
they were he stopped and they kept
pursuing some of them may have been
bitter because he didn't return their
advances but to call him some kind of
predator come on man
and here's the worst part is that since
he's released these receipts a lot of
the news outlets haven't picked it up so
the same people who condemned him but
never went out of their way with their
journalistic integrity to make those
Corrections we've seen that happen and
that always happened brother we're gonna
be really quick to condemn we're gonna
really be really quick to disrespect but
then after that that apology is nowhere
to be found
that's your apology should be louder as
loud as your disrespect and that's not
what happening that's not what happened
with news outlet oh it's not true well
okay
same thing that happened with Johnny
Depp and Emma and we know about that
what huh yeah what do we hear about that
nothing that's what news outlet if they
chose the line they're gonna keep on
going on that line even though if they
if they mess up you always say believe
all women but it you make it sound like
women don't lie I didn't know y'all were
the perfect I just wasn't aware that you
guys were the perfect gender incapable
of lying
come on guys let's be smart and let's be
better all right facts and evidence
that's the only thing I believe peace
[Music]
if you want to cut them down someone yes
you know bring the facts the truth don't
omit things you know I mean don't do
that and then you make a fake parallel
over an acting job I mean if he's a
creep
fine if you did some things that were
wrong fine there's no problem with that
nobody's disputing that but when you're
doing all this and you're a man oh wow
people are not just coming after him
because he went for young women who were
18 to 22 is that is that is that kind of
creepy maybe by your definition and your
title to that it doesn't make it wrong
it doesn't make it a punishable offense
and the thing that they're gonna be it's
gonna be known for as being a file even
though you're not yeah yeah because
there's nothing feel like about going
after women who are one poet past
puberty and to over 18 there's nothing
to do with that you have to be previous
in to qualify for that so I just hate
when people use these wrong terms one